Transcriptor: Chloé Etard
Revisor: Frank Zegarra
(Música)
Hola, ¿cómo están?
Bueno, pues.
Antes que nada, vamos a platicar
de esta cosa rara que está acá.
Yo soy diseñador de información
y también soy diseñador de tipografías.
Y es una cosa muy rara porque
yo me dedico todo el tiempo,
desde hace 15 años a hacer esto.
Esas cosas que nadie ve y que
normalmente, a nadie le importan,
que son las letras, ¿no?
En Enigma, que es mi empresa, que tengo
con dos socios desde hace once años,
hacemos tipografía a la medida.
Y es muy raro porque sí pertenece
al universo del diseño
pero, no quiero decir que estamos
en peligro de extinción, porque no.
Desde medianos del 1400, existen
los diseñadores de tipografía,
pero sí es muy raro, ¿no?
Es muy raro que alguién
se quiera dedicar a estas cosas.
En México, más o menos,
habemos unas diez personas que
nos dedicamos full time a hacer esto.
Por eso es tan escaso,
y en algún momento,
le llamaban el «Ars Negra».
Le llaman «Ars Negra», que en latín
quiere decir «Arte Negro»,
por dos razones.
La primera es la más obvia
que es que la tinta era negra,
y la segunda era porque
era un arte muy oscuro.
Pero ¿cómo nace todo esto
a través del diseño?
Pues miren, les cuento.
Hace exactamente cien años,
en 1919, surgió una escuela,
la primera escuela que empezó a juntar
las artes, la arquitectura y el diseño.
Surgió en Alemania, justamente
en el período de calma que hubo
entre las dos guerras mundiales.
Y justamente, la razón por la que surgió
es porque querían y veían al diseño
como una necesidad de cambio social.
Independientemente de la innovación
estética que proponían,
y que era bastante disruptiva,
era necesario entre ese período
de calma entre las dos guerras,
hacer un cambio paradigmático.
Pero, ¿quién fue la primera persona
que habló de diseño gráfico
como hoy lo entendemos?
Fue tres años más tarde en 1922,
y es este señor que curiosamente
es otro diseñador de tipografías.
Se llama William Addison Dwiggins,
y en su tiempo libre,
cuando no era diseñador,
hacía marionetas.
Ahí ustedes lo pueden ver con
su pequeña marionetita de el mismo.
Súper nerd.
Y justo cuando él veía sus marionetas
actuar en el escenario,
se daba cuenta de que las luces y todo
aplanaban la forma de las caras
y las expresiones.
Entonces, hizo una cosa
que le llamó la Fórmula-M,
donde enfatizaba y dramatizaba
toda la expresión de la cara,
para que con las luces y la distancia
en tamaños muy chiquitos,
—imagínense una marionetita así, aquí—
se percibieran bien los rasgos.
Y eso lo pasó a la tipografía.
Al lado izquierdo ustedes
ven Times New Roman,
que es practicamente lo que pasaría
si no dramatizáramos eso.
Y del lado derecho, tenemos
una fuente utilizando la Fórmula-M,
que justamente era para que
se viera bien en puntajes chiquitos.
Así surge el diseño.
El diseño surge como una respuesta
a la solución de un problema.
Que en ese momento era
leer en cuerpos chiquitos.
Ahora tristemente, nosotros hemos,
—ahí les van los datos duros—
tristemente nosotros hemos llevado
a que el diseño no sea percibido
de la misma manera hoy en día.
Hay una completa desvalorización
de lo que aparentemente el diseño es.
Y si ustedes ven el comportamiento
de búsqueda de las personas,
a nivel mundial,
en los últimos quince años,
es súper deprimente,
ver que la gente ya no
está interesada en diseño gráfico.
La gente sí está interesada en otras cosas
como por ejemplo, la pornografía.
Está muy chistoso como
la pornografía va en aumento,
y el diseño va en decadencia.
Pero justamente, no es exclusivo
del diseño gráfico,
porque si analizamos cosas como:
«Interior Design Studios»,
o «Architecture Studios»,
o lo que ya sabíamos
desde hace muchos años,
las agencias de web o,
bueno no, eso es sorprendente,
las agencias de publicidad, por ejemplo,
o la tendencia de búsqueda
de estudios de animación,
justamente vemos que la industria creativa
y la industria como ahora
conocemos como "Industria Naranja",
va en decadencia.
¿Por qué es esto?
Porque ya nos dimos cuenta,
que las soluciones estéticas
no sirven para nada.
Nos dimos cuenta que
el diseño en realidad
es una disciplina que tenemos
que verla como una actividad intelectual,
donde con conocimiento,
donde con reflexión,
con entendimiento,
con análisis,
vamos a crear soluciones que respondan
a un problema en específico.
La desvalorización del diseño
tiene que ver con muchas razones.
El que las personas crean
que los diseñadores estamos
acostados en una hamaca
en Playa del Carmen,
fumando un churro de mota, esperando
a que la inspiración divina solo llegue,
es culpa de nosotros.
Porque nosotros, no hemos podido
comunicar el poder del diseño.
No hemos podido verbalizar
lo que el diseño hace.
No hemos podido comunicar el método
y los procesos que seguimos.
Y esa imposibilidad de
articular el poder que tiene,
hace que nos vean como una industria
en la que solamente hacemos dibujitos,
que se ven bien bonitos.
Hay dos proyectos, que a mí
me gustan mucho,
que creo que les van a dejar más claro
el poder de la tipografía
como solucionador de problemas.
El primero es este,
que lo hizo un diseñador tipográfico
que se llama Matthew Carter,
el mismo que diseño Verdana, por ejemplo.
Y lo hizo para directorios telefónicos,
en cuerpo 6. Imagínense.
Un directorio telefónico
con mil páginas, cuerpo 6,
papel súper pobre, impresión rotativa.
Y de repente, hizo una solución
para que se viera bien.
Pero no solo eso, sino que,
una simple decisión,
tan tonta, aparentemente,
como no poner minúsculas,
hace que se pueda ahorrar
el 30 % de espacio.
Entonces imagínense
un directorio telefónico de mil páginas,
donde de repente,
pues ya no tengo
mil páginas, tengo 700.
Son 300 páginas menos
por directorio telefónico.
Eso serían como once pliegos
por directorio telefónico,
porque en cada pliego,
caben muchas páginas.
Si cada pliego costará
unos treinta centavos,
serían como 55 miliones de pesos
ahorrados en papel,
solamente por la estúpida decisión
de una tipografía.
Ahí es cuando el diseño,
no solamente el diseño editorial,
sino el diseño de la forma de la letra
puede cambiar una realidad muy cañón.
Esta es otra tipografía que diseñó
Thomas Huot-Marchand,
es un francés, que diseñó
la tipografía específicamente
para que se viera bien en cuerpo 2.
Se llama «Minuscule».
Hay «Minuscule 6», para cuerpo 6,
y después tenemos, 5,4,3,2.
Y esto es para cuerpo 2.
Y está increíble, ¿no?
poder imprimir una tipografía.
Todo esto, cuerpo 6 y cuerpo 2,
más o menos como en el 2011,
nos inspiró a resolver
un problema que nos plantearon:
¿Pueden diseñar una tipografía
que sirva para aumentar el nivel
de seguridad nacional del país?
Pues vamos a ver.
Y entonces empezamos a diseñar
una tipografía que iba a ser exclusiva
para documentos que necesitaran
un alto nivel de seguridad,
o sea que fueran
difícilmente falsificables.
Y de entrada, tenía que ser
una tipografía exclusiva,
que nadie tuviera,
ni siquiera nosotros después de terminarla
y que estuviera cerrada ahí
en casa de moneda,
y que nadie tuviera acceso.
Pues esta es la tipografía,
se llama «Kuukum».
Esta inspirada en el arte plumario.
Pero más que eso, es una tipografía
que esta pensada para tres puntajes.
Primero los textos que
son puntaje 7 u 8.
Los micro textos que
se leen con cuentahílos,
y son puntaje, a lo mejor 3, 4.
Y luego hay nano textos,
que se leen con microscopio,
y que puedes imprimir en
un cabello humano, todo un textito.
Entonces dijimos: ¿cómo diseñamos
una tipografía para nano textos?
No tenemos ni idea pero
hay que asumir el reto.
Entonces, si ustedes ven las diferencias
entre cada una de las letras,
hay cuestiones morfológicas,
de la forma de la letra,
que van cambiando
dependiendo el puntaje.
Hay menos contraste, es más ancha y demás.
Pero todo esto surge para resolver
un problema muy específico.
Es que alguien no pueda falsificar.
Esta imagen que ustedes ven acá es
Kuukum impresa en un milímetro de ancho.
En realidad ya no hay tinta.
Entonces mi concepción inicial era:
«a ver, vamos a poner trampas de tinta
y hacer que todo... y cuando caiga...»
pero ni siquiera hay tinta.
Entonces hay que romper
otra vez los paradigmas
de lo que resolver un problema
de diseño significa.
Y esta de acá es una imagen
de una fundición holandesa
que se llama Underware, que fotografió
la universidad de Delft
en un microscopio
justamente para evidenciar
el comportamiento de un texto,
en un micro texto.
Entonces el diseño, vamos
mucho más allá de hacer cosas bonitas.
Y después empezamos a hacer
un ejercicio donde dijimos:
"¿Cómo podemos aumentar más
el nivel de seguridad?"
Y entonces empezamos
a diseñar y a diseñar
un montón de variaciones de la letra,
pero variaciones que fueran
difíciles de percibir
por el usuario no entrenado,
y que entonces, de repente,
cuando tu escribes la frase de:
"Bananas de Alabama"
donde hay muchas 'a',
todas las 'a' son distintas
pero no sabes por qué.
Y entonces, si quisieras
falsificar un documento,
con un algoritmo bastante sencillo
y bastante tonto que hicimos,
todo va cambiando de forma
semi aleatoria y controlada.
Y entonces, pues tú no sabes
si esa 'B' es la 'B' 44
y si después le sigue la 'a' 102
y si luego le sigue la 'n' quinta.
Entonces con una solución muy básica
está resolviendo un problema muy complejo
como la seguridad nacional.
Aquí es cuando entonces
entendemos que el diseño
se vuelve un creador de soluciones
para resolver problemas muy específicos.
Y mucho más importantes
y transcendentales que
la frivolidad gráfica,
o la frivolidad estética.
Existe este otro proyecto que
les voy a contar muy brevemente,
pero, cuando yo era niño, siempre
veía a mi papá que estudió
educación especial y pedagogía musical.
Y tenía una orquesta de niños sordos.
Era muy impactante ver eso.
Y entonces, siempre pensé:
¿cómo es que los sordos,
no mudos, solamente sordos,
se integran a la sociedad?
Y ese proceso se llama
como comunicación total,
que son todas estas partes.
Las más básicas, sería
la lectura labiofacial
y la expresión corporal tiene que ver
con recibir información,
pero después sigue:
lenguaje de señas, lenguaje pictográfico.
El decir: "Casa" o el decir: "Hola".
Y después viene la vocalización
que es lo más difícil.
Pero todo este proceso depende mucho
de un chorro de cosas:
del tiempo que tengas,
del dinero que tengas
para pagar las terapías,
de la motivación de la persona,
de la psicología, incluso
de su propia cognición.
Y se pone más difícil cuando
todavía entendemos,
que hay sonidos, dependiente
completamente del idioma,
hay unos más dificiles que otros,
donde tenemos sonidos aislados,
sonidos en contexto y sonidos conjugados.
Entonces resulta que una 'C' en el español
tiene cinco, seis, siete, ocho
formas de pronunciarse.
Y la 'G' cinco más.
Y la 'A' otras más.
Entonces resulta un problema muy complejo.
Y de repente por ahí me acordé una vez
que había una tipografía que habían hecho
Erik van Blockland y Just van Rossum,
que era la primera tipografía generativa.
En este momento, ellos eran estudiantes
de la escuela de artes
de La Haya, en Holanda.
Entonces, diseñaron esto para justamente
violentar al significado de la tipografía.
Porque era una tipografía...
Una tipografía normalmente
es una letra prefabricada.
Es una letra que hacemos,
ya sea en plomo o en vectores,
y después cuando nosotros escribimos,
todo el tiempo es igual.
A diferencia de la caligrafía,
que lo hacemos en el momento
y todo el tiempo es diferente.
En este caso, lo que ellos hicieron
fue hacer justamente una tipografía que,
ven, ya estoy contando más,
justamente hicieron una tipografía
que estuviera prefabricada,
pero que en el momento que la imprimían
todo el tiempo se comportaba
de forma diferente.
Su contorno se rompía y
todo el tiempo era diferente.
Imagínense la cantidad de permutaciones
que podríamos tener.
Eso justamente sirvió para que
yo visualizará este modelo donde
un sordo puede prácticar constentemente
en el desarollo de una aplicación
que hay un 'input' y hay un 'output'.
Cuando yo meto un sonido
a través de un micrófono,
el sistema reacciona y entonces
puedo visualizar justamente
si el sonido que estoy generando es
efectivamente una 'A', una 'B', una 'C',
tengo retroalimentación inmediata,
no tengo que ir a terapia,
no tengo que pagar por que
una persona me este sintiendo:
"A ver, produce: 'vvvv, vaca' ".
Y es a través de vibraciones,
entonces imagínense
lo difícil que podría ser, estar
validando a través de vibraciones,
si lo estoy haciendo bien o no.
Cuando la tipografía y la tecnología
me podrían ayudar al respecto.
Finalmente, eso se puede redondear
con la idea de que la voz de cada quien
puede representarse de una manera distinta
a través de la tipografía.
Tal cual como lo hacen las marcas.
Una marca que tiene su logotipo
decide minuciosamente
que quiere comunicar
a través de las letras.
Esa es la razón por la que ustedes
por ejemplo nunca han leído
un libro de Borges en Comic Sans.
Porque la forma de la letra
no empata con el contenido.
Entonces todo el tiempo
tenemos inconscientemente,
si vemos un libro de Borges
en Comic Sans decimos:
"¡Qué horror! ¿Quién hizo esto?"
Y es justamente lo que pasa
con nuestra voz,
con la personalidad de las letras,
tienen personalidad,
a parte de toda la funcionalidad
que les he ido contando poco a poco.
Entonces, aquí es cuando
justamente el diseño
se vuelve el intermediario entre
la comunicación y el entendimiento.
El diseño es ese elemento que hace
que la mente de alguien
puede entender algo,
o la mente de otra persona.
Justo el objecto de estudio
es la cognición.
Es poder hacer,
el diseño hace que los humanos
podemos entendernos.
A través de una señal en un aeropuerto,
a través de un libro,
a través de un producto.
Eso es justamente
la trascendencia del diseño.
Ahora,
ya para ir cerrando,
este es el comportamiento de búsqueda
completamente opuesto.
¿Qué es lo que busca?
y ¿cuáles son las tendencias que generan
el diseño hoy en día y hacía dónde vamos?
Pues básicamente, lo que ustedes
están viendo es la tendencia de búsqueda
de términos como: 'Design Thinking',
que hoy ustedes conocen mucho,
y que justamente el Design Thinking
es una estrategia mercadológica
de posicionar una palabra
o un 'keyword', para decir algo más.
Pero si nadie hubiera inventado
el término 'Design Thinking',
¿qué estarían buscando las personas,
en los buscadores mundiales?
Pues estaríamos buscando:
'Solution-Based Design',
o estaríamos buscando:
'Purpose-Driven Design',
que justamente es el diseño
como solucionador de un problema,
o que tiene objetivos
muy específicos que cumplir.
Y entonces cuando vemos todo este cruce,
vemos que más o menos en 2010
es el punto de quiebre.
Pero ese punto de quiebre
no es fortuito, y no es reciente.
Porque viene de mucho tiempo atrás.
Llevamos más de 25 000 años
comunicándonos gráficamente.
Llevamos más o menos de 1922, 1919,
como les contaba al inicio,
cien años entendiendo al diseño gráfico,
más o menos correctamente.
Y después en los 50, surge
el diseño de información,
que es la carrera que yo estudié,
y que hasta el 2003 o el 2002,
era la primera vez que
se enseñaba en México.
Ahora tenemos cosas
como 'Design Thinking',
o, como el más reciente
'Diseño Estratégico'.
Pero es justamente esa labor,
entender que el diseño existe
para enriquecer realidades existentes.
Para eso se creó el diseño.
Para mejorar a la realidad
de una persona,
que hoy no sabe hablar,
pero podría hablar más facilmente.
Que hoy no se ubica en un entorno,
pero que yo podría ayudar
a través del diseño
a que llegue más rápido
a su destino, en una señal.
Que hoy no puede entender
la mente de un pensador,
pero yo a través de tipografía,
puedo tangibilizar ese pensamiento.
O que puedo aumentar el nivel
de seguridad de un país. Por ejemplo.
Entonces, mi conclusión
sería que, el diseño,
está para servirnos en la vida cotidiana,
ese es su objetivo.
Y hay que entender que el futuro
llega un día a la vez.
Y justamente, cada vez más,
somos capaces de evaluar y comprobar
que lo que estamos haciendo
sirve para algo.
Ese es nuestra labor en el mundo.
Aristóteles decía, con otras palabras,
decía que el tiempo, ese que
hoy es presente y mañana es futuro,
entendido con profundidad,
es la dimensión física que nos ayuda
a entender el cambio.
Para eso sirve el tiempo.
Y es una dimensión
completamente intangible,
no es una dimensión como
ancho, alto y profundidad.
Es una dimensión que tenemos
que utilizar un artefacto para decir:
"Ya es la una, ya es la dos,
ya son las tres..."
Pero si lo entenderíamos con profundidad,
realmente entenderíamos
que el tiempo nos ayuda
a entender el cambio:
el "como éramos" y hacía donde vamos.
Lo que sí quiero decir, es que
todo el diseño y todo lo que se expone
en este tipo de escenarios,
la intención es poder entender
todo lo que somos;
y no solamente todo lo que somos,
sino todo lo que hacemos
para cambiar lo que somos
en términos de mejora humana.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)